Повний вперед! Без обмеження швидкості! Тисни на газ - і ні про що не думай!
Це - поширене уявлення про автобани в Німеччині.
А це реальність:
затори без кінця-краю, куди не глянь. До початку пандемії ті, хто щодня використовував
автомобіль, проводив у заторах приблизно 120 годин на рік, тобто 5 повних днів.
Але з чим це пов'язано? Звісно, з аваріями. А ще - з нескінченними ремонтами доріг.
Тільки до 2025 року в Німеччині заплановано понад 100 великих будівельних проєктів.
Проблема в тім, що дорожня інфраструктура застаріла й занепала.
Є пошкоджені траси та мости, що розвалюються -
лише в цьому році утримання мережі автомобільних доріг обійдеться німцям у 4,5 мільярда євро.
Фактично десятиліттями нічого не робилося, а багато споруд збудували ще в 1970-ті роки.
Йдеться про мости, тунелі -  вони елементарно зістарилися.
Не варто забувати й про вантажні перевезення.
Важкі фури часто є не лише причиною пробок. Вони також псують дороги.
Навантаження на поверхню доріг від вантажівок є рази більше.
Вісь однієї вантажівки завдає автобану приблизно такої шкоди, як тисяча осей легкових авто.
Як же завадити занепаду?
Одна з ідей - модернізація дорожнього будівництва.
З'явилися нові суміші для дорожнього покриття, які допомогають краще витримувати великі навантаження.
Але чи дійсно це - правильний підхід?
Треба враховувати ще один важливий фактор, що впливає на наше життя.
Це зміна клімату.
Транспортний сектор відстає в питанні скорочення викидів парникових газів.
Я думаю, що зараз це усвідомили.
Протяжність автобанів у Німеччині - 13 тисяч кілометрів.
Купа місця для встановлення сонячних батарей.
Наприклад, на мостах і узбіччях.
Утім, наразі все це - лише пілотні проєкти.
Що дійсно допомогло б захисту клімату, так це знайти альтернативу автобанам.
Особливо якщо казати про вантажні перевезення: скільки можна віддати залізниці?
Трубопроводи, внутрішнє судноплавство, вантажні поїзди, фури - досі саме на фури припадала більша частина перевезень.
Але саме вони виділяють і найбільше вуглекислого газу (CO2) на тонну перевезеного вантажу.
Річ у тому, що вантажний транспорт розвинувся з появою сучасних виробничих систем -
перевезення "точно в строк", складні виробничі ланцюжки, виробничі мережі, що тягнуться по всій Європі.
До 2030 року частку залізничних перевезень збільшать щонайменше до 25 відсотків.
Якщо хочете знову більше задіяти залізницю, то перевезення нею повинні мати переваги фур:
бути гнучкими і здійснювати швидкі поставки по всій Європі.
У сусідів Німеччини справи йдуть краще. В Австрії та Швейцарії більше товарів перевозиться залізницею.
Але є ще одна ідея.
У Швейцарії нині обговорюється можливість доставки вантажів в міста без допомоги фур і вантажних поїздів.
Йдеться про підземну систему тунелів.
Але для початку їх ще потрібно побудувати.
Така система працює за принципом пневматичної пошти, який використовувався раніше.
Існують також рішення, які не вимагають таких великих інвестицій в інфраструктуру,
адже прокладка тунелів є складним процесом і не зовсім захищає клімат.
Я маю на увазі автоматичні перевантажувальні комплекси, автоматичні системи зчеплення, нові організаційні концепції.
Це цілий майданчик технологічних можливостей.
А як на практиці змусити компанії перейти від автомобільних перевезень до залізничних?
Перш за все, гадаю, важливо, щоб дорожній рух також компенсував витрати, які він створює, в тому числі і для широких мас.
Будь-то витрати на систему охорони здоров'я, захист довкілля абощо.
Таким чином будуть розраховані справжні витрати, і в той же час це буде сприяти переорієнтації на користь залізниці.
І тоді, нарешті, менше фур, а отже - вільні дороги і їзда без обмеження швидкості?
Не зовсім:
З точки зору науки про дорожній рух має сенс встановити обмеження швидкості не для того,
щоб автомобілі рухалися повільніше, а для того, щоб швидкості всіх учасників дорожнього руху на дорозі були вирівняні.
Таким чином пропускна здатність стала б вищою.
Прощавай, кліше!
Транспортна політика Німеччина повинна змінити свій курс.
І почати це можна із запровадження обмеження швидкості на автобанах.